so this is a really typical question
i've called it by the way i forgot to
mention this and start
i've called it introductory curve
sketching okay because i said to you
before when you know the derivative
it tells it tells you lots of useful
things about
what something looks like what a graph
behaves like okay
and so we're going to put that onto a
graph but it's introductory because
there's more stuff
which we're going to put onto this graph
later on which we don't quite know yet
okay so
one step at a time so this is what a
typical question will look like it'll
say part a
and it's just going to be testing your
understanding of calculus okay and then
part b
let's see if you can make a pretty
drawing out of it okay so let's start
with part a
like locate all stationary points of y
equals x
cubed minus x let's just do that bit
first okay so stationary points do you
remember
they occur when
stationary points exist
when what was our condition what's our
condition
good so i need to find d y and dx right
and uh
then once i've got it i can solve for
when it's equal to zero
okay so in this case d y on dx
is equal to well look at it it's not
that hard to work with
x cubed turns into 3x squared
and that x on the end will just turn
into 1.
great so therefore for stationary points
i'm gonna say that's equal to zero right
three x
squared is equal to sorry three x
squared minus one
is equal to zero so let's just solve it
three x squared equals
one x squared equals a
third so x is plus or minus
1 3. so far so good
okay now it says locate all stationary
points so
if we want to find where these points
are we don't just need their
x-coordinate we also need their
y-coordinate right so we're gonna have
to take these two
this is actually two values right
negative
and positive okay i'm gonna have to
bring them back into my original
equation here
to get their values okay so let's
quickly do that
grab a sheet
okay so we'll do the left one first the
negative one okay
um minus one on root three that's a
pretty gross number
when you cube it what happens when you
cube it what happens
minus one cubed is also minus one
the sorry not the cube root the square
root of three
you cube it so root three times root
three times root three
i'm going to have three three root three
right
okay uh yeah by the way i've sort of
been a little bit messy i mean we could
rationalize these i could say that's
root through negative root three
on three and we could say that this is
this would be
negative root three on nine right
but i'm gonna let it slide that's not
really the main point here okay
i've got some coordinates for that
that's good
uh that's sorry that's the x cubed and
now i need the other part
the minus x which is minus
minus 1 and root 3. okay so double
negative there they're going to cancel
so i'm going to get positive 1 over root
3
minus 1 on 3 root 3.
okay and i can bring these two together
kind of because this is really
three on three root three right
so three minus one
there's our value okay now really
quickly
because later on we're going to be
graphing this at this point having
worked this out it's actually going to
be useful for us
to work out what is that approximately
equal to
okay like as a decimal because i don't i
don't know what that looks like when i
try to picture
what it is because i don't know what
this value is so root 3 is like 1.7
thereabouts so 3 times 1.3 is about 5
5.1 so i'm guessing this is close to 0.4
does anyone want to verify that for me
what's the actual number give me two
decimal places zero point
three three yeah okay
all right so close enough now i'm just
gonna use that for later so that my
scale isn't you know
nuts right there's one of them now
this is one of the cool things right
when i say i want to work out the
other stationing point and its location
okay
i could go through all of this all right
but there's a shortcut
you know to actually work this out right
because earlier this year we were
looking at
functions with different kinds of
symmetry right what were the two kinds
do you remember
on an even so when you look at this okay
when you look at it
x cubed is an odd function
sorry x is also an odd function
okay so therefore when you take the
difference between them you'll get
another odd function yes so
thank you i can say
if i know that this is one of the roots
okay and i've got this
sorry not roots stationary points i can
say the other stage three point is going
to be
where are you going to be expecting it's
an odd function right so odd functions
mean
um f of minus
x is minus f of x right
one side is the other side upside down
okay
so therefore where are you expecting the
unstationary point
it's going to be negative right one side
is negative the other so i can say
straight away
that this is going to be negative 2 on 3
root 3.
okay which is negative 0.38
okay good so so far what have i done i
have
um located all the stationary points
these are all of the different solutions
okay so i guess i probably should to be
neat i should say
stationary points exist at
and then i should put them in coordinate
form right so the first one is
um let's see minus one unless you on
through three
two on three three so that's one
coordinate
and i've got the other one which is the
same thing as backwards
okay great now what's